hey this you could friend army Jimmy
John's told me to tell you and he would
love to review my new movie old man
still kicks ass always people like to
call it last stand but unfortunately
it's gonna be in Los Angeles California
for the next few days so we can't do it
delicates back but until then he's going
to reveal a movie for you and completely
[ __ ] forgettable so let's do it
broken city so broken city stars Mark
Wahlberg and Russell Crowe Mark
Wahlberg's gonna like Dirty Harry
Russell Crowe's are really corrupt ass
politician so that after getting canned
Mark Wahlberg becomes a P I and Russell
Crowe hires him to investigate his wife
who's Catherine zeta-jones and then
after that you got a lot of corruption
and cops and dirty politics and just a
bunch of things that you're like oh
that's interesting that's interesting
that's interesting if done well however
it's in this movie that's just a
convoluted mess that's why I can put it
I mean really tough cop who's kind of a
dirty cop but a guy who can root for
interesting for a movie corrupt
politician whose wife's sleeping around
behind his back and he wants her
investigated interesting enough for a
movie not really that interesting now or
another cop who may be a dirty cop maybe
he's not a dirty cop who's owned by a
mayor and they got that whole thing
going on in election season okay
interesting enough right not enough for
this movie this is one of those movies
where you look at the cast and you're
like Russell Crowe gets work Mark
Wahlberg gets work at what point where
they like I'm gonna do this smart career
move and be in this movie Catherine
zeta-jones I understand she's had a
couple of straight to DVD releases
lately and I get it just like I'm
starting to look the age where it's
socially acceptable for Michael Douglas
to be married to me so she needs work
she can't rely on her looks forever this
movies directed by one of the huge
brothers he's one of the guys who
directed from Hell Book of Eli you need
the whole team to make a good movie with
these guys otherwise you get one guy who
makes Farooq in city but I say the
movies a sloppy mess I really mean it's
a sloppy mess I mean Mark Wahlberg has
this girlfriend who his girlfriend is
works from the movie she's an actress he
sees her in a movie he just freaks out
about it he's a recovering alcoholic but
then he goes on a drinking binge and
then now it's just it's this thing real
like oh he fell off the wagon but after
that every time you see him pop a drink
it's just no big deal he's like well I
guess I do this again you all right I
guess we were made to care for one
second now we just don't give a [ __ ]
that he isn't getting drunk I can just
see the pitch meeting for this like yeah
Mark Wahlberg falls off the wagon and
he's just he's a mess and he's a wreck
someone else is like well does he drink
throughout the movie or is it just like
a one-time thing oh I didn't think about
that yeah he drinks throughout the movie
sure I mean are we supposed to care
about that is it business as usual only
now he has a glass of scotch right now
how does this work
I don't know shut up okay just shut just
stop it stop it stop it you're thinking
too deep into it it's a movie
God's sakes another thing is the trailer
shows too much you're not supposed to
know where people are coming from for
the first half of the movie which makes
you feel kind of in the dark and you
wonder why you give a [ __ ] and why
you're watching the movie but the point
is you're supposed to be in the dark but
if you saw the trailer you know who the
douche bags are and who the douche bags
aren't and then what happens Mark
Wahlberg's like I'm gonna take this
action it's the last 15 minutes of the
movie but hey I saw this in the trailer
so one of those movies it's about an
hour and 45 minute long movie watch the
trailer save yourself an hour 42 and a
half minutes best advice I can give you
you've seen the premise of this movie a
hundred times on television
perfect for television as a movie you
walked out going well that's why I stick
to TV I will say broken cities not dog
[ __ ] but you're still not gonna remember
it in t minus 15 minutes yep I already
forgot that [ __ ] are your favorite dirty
cop movie whatever it may be
comment below let me know don't know why
I asked that it's really not a dirty cop
movie but it's what I choose to ask and
as always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more